Alright, how about this? We've seen just INT.
One of our grammar rules is A goes to INT + string--
INT + string--and I've put the dot right here, so we've already seen an INT,
and we're expecting to see 2 more things.
This is consistent with the world that we've been presented.
We know that eventually this won't work because the full input is INT + INT,
but we haven't seen that much yet, so we can't rule it out.
Right now we think this state is okay.
In the future, we'll give up on it.
Similarly, one of the rules in our grammar is A goes to INT.
We've only seen an INT, so we could be in this state.
The INT is behind us. There's nothing in our future.
We're really hoping the input ends now.
The input doesn't end now.
You and I know that there are 2 more tokens coming,
but our parser doesn't know that yet. It's only seen 1 token.
In the next step, the next iteration, the next recursive call,
it will know and throw away this information.
But for now, we're keeping it.
Alright, how about this?
A goes to INT +--this requires us to have 2 tokens in the past,
and we've only seen 1 token of the input.
That can't be true.
Similarly over here, there's nothing in the past, and there's 1 token to the right.
Looking at our grammar. There's really no way this could play out.
We've seen 1 token, and this assumes we've seen 0.
Over here, similarly, INT + string--this parsing state only works if we've seen 0 tokens,
and we've already seen 1. So that doesn't match.
And in fact, similarly here, S goes to A. S goes to A is a rule in our grammar.
That's a good sign, but this version requires us to have seen nothing,
and we've seen 1 token.
S goes to A, and here we are.
Actually this could totally work.
If I've only seen just INT from the input, then I could be finishing off--
I could be accepting the string based on S goes to A and A goes to INT.
So I've already seen a full A. A goes to INT--and now I'm done with S.
Yeah! That's where I could be.
Now again, we're going to rule this out as soon as we see the next token in the input--
that it's not the end of the string, but for now, it looks very promising.
This is the big trick with parsing, I said earlier, we'd have to keep our fingers in many spots
because until we see the whole input, we're not sure what the picture is.